para portugal a missão mais um vídeo e
vamos continuar fazendo isso até um
papel aqui é possível receber um prémio
num concurso que nós estamos a fazer
entre canais os canais participantes
estão na descrição ok
quer dizer é o link do álbum da banda
que também fizeram o primeiro desafio
deste concurso é fazer um avião que
tenha maior tempo de vôo e só aí
prometeu creio de avião para tentar
ganhar e pronto eu fiz aqui um avião que
tem aqui amanhã eu tenho maior dinâmica
que lhe permita levantar muito concentra
muita massa daqui a frei conseguiu
lançar mais alto aos maior para
preencher o maior tempo vou seja vital
mas prevê que uma causa por ganhar 8
bill depois também fiz aqui um de
tamanho portanto para que esse objetivo
mas ao fazer aumentar a massa aqui que
não tem muito resistente já usei este
ano está um pouco machucada mas eu já
fui lançar muitas vezes só foi com isso
que eu fiz o teste toque própria
companhia também não viu muita
resistência frontal
agora o texto depois o tutorial faça o
passo por lá
em pessoal pra você fazer um avião que
acabaram de ver vou precisar de duas
folhas a4 de impressora ou então do
ofício é usar só uma folha então no
total no final tanto a parte usar uma
folha para usar outra folha é juntando a
área desses duas partes vai dar à área
de uma folha branca está aqui na linha
do centro mesmo para este lado aí para
ser igual vamos só no brasil assim que
seja esta tem que ser agora aqui na
linha
fazer mesmo outro lado como objetivo do
concurso era o tempo do vôo
eu criei aqui um avião com as grandes
atingir uma altura muito grande
concentra muito peso que vai permitir
lançar muito alto vocês viram no início
da partida ficar em cima do avião caísse
desrespeito a uma lei da física em que
nós aumentarmos a partida do avião eu
não fui levantar para cima
agora vamos tirar esta parte aqui é
muito grande aqui dentro
o componente tem uma distância
agora é só sobre o por outro lado igual
pediram muito capacete na cabeça a
cabeça é tão bom como é muito boa
mais uma vez o problema e isso causa
agora como está a ser marcada reforçada
agora vou dobrar travesti para a mãe que
esta parte não só vocês podem continuar
a achar as sugestões do jec que eu já
fiz algumas sugestões que vocês poderão
planteis minutos
agora nesta parte aqui vocês vão deixar
e 3424 realizado e vou rasgar sempre
fora então podem cortar só que agora
procurador e assim vão juntar assim e
agora o dobro pra fora
agora as coisas no avião mas ainda não
está claro só vocês vão desdobrar para
enganar o avião vocês vão trazer aqui
está a par do bic em frente à casa em
que estava centralizado dobram de volta
e já está agora a parte mais importante
você tem que regular esta via ok porque
é que vai variar de pessoa não vai cair
vocês vão ter que regular lo aqui pra
cima aqui e aqui também podem jogar aqui
com o que fazer porque eu mesmo e pronto
a coisa vai ficar muito mais você juntar
com cola vai ficar mais forte
a linha inscreva-se frio também o vídeo
dos outros é isso